Alright folks, welcome back. This is going to be a short little ditty on the S&P 500
June contract 2022. This is our daily chart. And before I get into it, just let me remind
you that I do not use WhatsApp. I'm not going to be in the comment section asking you to
reach out to me. Okay, hit me up. Let's talk. None of that stuff. That's all scammers. So
I'm never going to ask you for money. I'm not going to direct message you. I'm not going
to direct message you on Twitter. Okay, all those people are just trying to scam you, trying
to pretend to be me. I'm not asking for your money. You're here to eat off my table for
free and I'm happy to do it. So just know that those accounts are not me. Please report them
and ignore them. Alright, so the S&P 500 daily chart, we're going to look at this day here.
And before we get into it, I'm going to bring your attention to the 16th of May on that
low. This morning on Twitter, I was not able to participate in the early session movement
on the stock indices because I've been trying to do things to share with the audience that
has been mainly following me because of Forex. I noticed a lot of you are starting to evaluate
and complain that you want to see Forex. And I understand that, but even my paid membership
group, they have seen very little in terms of Forex too. And I'm pushing this asset class
because this is where the volatility is. Price is price. It doesn't make a difference. When
Forex starts moving around big again, trust me, index futures will get slower and quiet
in comparison to Forex. Trust me when I tell you the currency markets will eventually,
within the next 12 months or so, probably start having some pretty wild movement.
But until then, we have to look for volatility where we can find it. Right now is in the stock
index market. So if you're a hardliner, if you're a purist and you don't want to see these types of
moves in this type of market, I understand, but learn from it because it works the same way
in Forex. Just know that. Okay. So I mentioned on Twitter that I was in the dollar CAD this morning.
I went long on that one on its high impact news at 830 and it was a snooze fest. It took forever
just to move a little bit. Obviously I shared that on the Twitter feed. So you can again,
go over and look at that. So I mentioned I was going to grab a bite to eat, have some lunch,
and then I would look to see if there's anything for the stock industry market.
And I participated in this move I'm going to show you today here.
I hinted at where the market was likely to go to. And let me state this going forward because
I had Perry Mason over there on Twitter reach out to me saying that the bar has been lowered
for calling out trades. I don't call out trades. I'm not going to put you in a trade. I'm not
going to give you an entry, a stop, a target. I'm not going to do that. I don't spoon feed. I don't
do that with my pay group. What I do is I point to where the market's going to go. I've already
taught you how to get in. I've already taught you where to put a stop loss. I've already taught you
how to put your limit orders in. I already taught you all that. Now the problem is you don't have
the experience of knowing where it's going to likely go next. So this morning, what I did was
I drew everyone's attention to the low on the 16th of May, 2022. Now, if the market is above
and let's go into a lower time frame chart. Okay. And if we're in the market
and we're up here and I'm suggesting to everyone think about this low over here on the 16th. What
do you think I'm drawing your attention to while we're up here and I'm drawing your attention to
this specific area, the lows of May 16, 2022? Do you think I'm referring to it as it should not
come back down here? No, everyone should understand my style is we're aiming for liquidity.
So if it's up here and I'm pointing down here and taking your attention down there, I'm acting like
a scout. You're the sniper in training, whether you realize it or not. Okay. So I'm trying to point
you to where you should be aiming and you have to do the work of scoping it up, pulling the trigger
and dealing with all that. Okay. So there's no shortcut to this.
There's not going to be an ICT on Twitter or on YouTube that sits down in front of you and says,
okay, everybody are you ready? We're all going to buy right now. We're all going to put our stop
loss at the same place. We're all going to put our exit or at the same place. And we're all going to
ride these things and this is going to be happy. And that's it. I'm not going to do that. I never
promised to do that. I'm not going to do it. Period. End of story. No way. This is how I train my
students. It works, folks. It does not work for lazy people. Okay. I understand that some of you
just want to be handheld, but that's not going to happen with me. I don't do it. I didn't do it when
people paid me and I'm not going to do it for free either. So you don't need me to hold your hand.
If I point to where I think the market's going to go, it's your job to study and look for the
opportunity. The fair value gap is what you're going to be utilizing. Okay. Some of you are
fixated on only looking for the setup at the opening. Well, what happens if you don't get a
trade at the opening? Can't you use a fair value gap to get involved with the move if it's going
to go down to something like this? Yes. And that's what I did today. So let me add the annotations
in the form of showing you the executions so that way you can see. I'm not sure why this thing is
not popping up. Stay on there. There you go. All right. So here is where I entered. I did four
contracts at 4,007 and three quarters aiming for the 16th below. I didn't have a whole lot of time
to be babysitting this thing. And late afternoon, this could have easily whipped up, did some kind
of retracement without any kind of stop loss, trail down, and then even moved lower. So just
to make it easy, short and sweet to the point, your attention was drawn to the 16th, the low on
the 16th of May. Let's go into a 15 minute time frame. All right. So you can see
up close candle. What do you think that is right before we started to go lower? It's a bearish
order block. Throw that out in time. It hits that order block on this candle here.
Dropping into a five minute chart. What is this?
It doesn't look like a bear until you zoom in, huh? So right in here, it's hitting,
it overshoots it granted, but it's a lot of volatility right now.
This candle is high. Your stop would be above there. Hold on to the position until it starts
to break lower. If you want to fine tune it, this is the one I shared on Twitter in the recording.
Okay. So what I saw was this fairway gap here, it hit it, created what? What is this?
What's this pattern here? What's these three candles here? It's a swing high. So as soon as
this candle closed here, I'm going to go right in here at this candle and just get in and go short,
trusting the fact that we've already had a fair value gap. We already went through it.
We have a swing high and it's bearish. I'm looking for what? What am I looking for? I'm looking for
what am I looking for? I'm looking for a run below this old low, which is May 16th, 2022 is low.
So I'm entering here and I'm riding it out with a stop here. Everything is reduced in terms of
risk. As soon as we started to break lower here and started moving in my favor aggressively,
I moved my stop only because the volatility is so high right now. I just don't want to see it come
back and knock me out. That's not fear. That's just sound money management. I'm not trying to
take a losing trade. So here is the entry again. It delivers on the downside. I took my first partial
here, one off here, and in a limit order, you watch that fill on the little recording, the
vignette that I shared on Twitter. Ultimately, we started going a little bit sideways going into
the beginning of lunch in New York. Here's your typical lunch time consolidation.
And then what's this? Stops ahead of lunch. Fair guy you got.
It's almost like it knows what it wants to do. Breaks lower. Consolidation again.
Trades lower. Consolidation bumps to stops here. What's this?
Oh, this ICT just makes it so complicated. Hits it, sells off. Sell side here. Consolidates one more
time and trades and meets the low of the day. I think I'm on this one now. It's the lowest candle
though at 39.10. Not bad. So that is what I did today. I did not participate in the afternoon
session post-New York lunch. This is all I had to share today. Right there.
There. There. And there. Okay. That's going to be it for today. Hopefully you enjoyed this and
found it insightful. Until I talk to you tomorrow, be safe.